hey what's up everybody i am dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for
today july 26 2021 this is my last
monday before going
off the grid that's right this friday
will be my last
show until september 1st
no phone no tv no news no current events
no nothing i'm going to sit quietly
catch up on a little reading relax let
the brain reset
let the world continue to go on and see
what happens
so we have a big big big week for you
here
shows every day obviously big live
stream on friday
where i will announce the pre-sale and
the title
of my new book which i can't wait to
share with you we're going to make some
uh announcements about locals and
there's just a lot going on
before i get into all the stuff about
today's show um
i was in south dakota for freedom fest
for a couple days last week
went to mount rushmore uh was just
hanging out with a bunch of
freedom-loving people
in south dakota and it was just
absolutely great
there is hope in this great country and
i just wanted to say that i am just
feeling good right now and that's
the feeling that i'm going to try to
take through this week
speaking of south dakota i bumped into
my friend and last week
last week's guest uh of the reuben
report uh larry elder
over at freedom fest we were doing a
book signing right next to each other
and a spectacular new poll just came out
can we throw this on the screen this is
from emerson
college and this is polling for the
california
recall election and larry elder who just
got in last week a lot of these guys
have been in for quite some time
he is basically leading all the
candidates against gavin newsom he's now
at 16
john cox 6 caitlyn jenner for a couple
others
right around there undecided 53
but this is great great news okay
larry is the one that can do this if
there is any hope
for this crazy state and maybe there
isn't but i am a dreamer and i know i'm
not the only one
then i think larry elder is the guy that
can topple newsome
i do want to add one other thing on this
we're going to show you a headline over
here
caitlyn jenner the thing is just a
completely made-up pr stunt which was
what i was worried about from the
beginning
caitlyn jenner is actually in sydney
australia right now for the next couple
weeks
shooting big brother so yeah it's
all a pr stunt um so let's assume that
that four percent
basically moves over to larry elder now
larry's at about 20
a couple of those other people drop you
get some of the undecideds move they all
start coalescing
around larry and then maybe maybe guys
california has a chance i i think it's
possible i actually think it's possible
we shall see three stories for you this
week uh aoc remember that
that gal she is a liar and i'm going to
show you some
video on that because once again they
are claiming
that unless you want critical race
theory taught in our schools
then you don't want racism taught and
this is just a lie this is the new meme
that they're pushing if
if we can't teach critical race theory
then we can't teach racism at all and
it's like
every single one of us that went to
public school in america have been
taught racism
i don't know anyone republican
independent anywhere else that doesn't
want racism or an honest assessment
of our history taught but that's the new
meme that is out there amongst
the lying class of which aoc is a part
that's story number one
story number two the former white house
physician
who has worked under at least three
administrations uh he is basically
saying something ain't right with biden
and we
we may need to start talking about the
the 25th amendment
uh if you didn't see it biden did a town
hall on cnn
last week i didn't cover it because
obviously i was traveling but he had
several sort of mental breakdowns
long-winded
answers that went absolutely nowhere
it's becoming
more and more obvious that he has i
don't want to say dementia
but at least he has ops old person
syndrome
and at what point does it fully burst
forth into the mainstream well now a
white house physician
who was a respected white house
physician as i said worked under
several presidents well now he's being a
little more forceful about some of the
language on some of this stuff
and then finally obviously we're going
to talk a little bit about covid because
it does seem like it's
covid round two it seems like it's
slightly back what's going on delta
variant
now fauci wants uh vaccinated people to
wear
masks uh but you're not gonna believe
this we found tweets
from msnbc hosts saying the complete
reverse a year ago that they're saying
now
and do you think it might have had
something to do with that orange man
being president and now they got
old person syndrome biden in charge i
think it has something to do with that
guys before i get to any of that i want
to talk to you about taser you know the
world in 2021 can feel like an unstable
and dangerous place
but we can't live in fear ain't it the
truth taser is giving people the
confidence to protect themselves by
creating
life-saving defense technology taser's
line of non-lethal self-protection
devices are small and lightweight enough
to carry with you or in your glove
compartment
or purse yet they're powerful enough to
incapacitate an attacker
guns carry risks for you and those
around you and even pepper spray can
harm you as much as an attacker
and it's often ineffective taser
products are safer and easier to use
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds allowing you time to escape
and send for help taser devices come
loaded with features
like laser assisted targeting and
emergency dispatch
which will send response teams to your
gps location upon firing
more than 237 000 lives have been saved
with the taser network of devices apps
and personnel protect yourself and your
family with taser's line of smart
self-defense products
unlike solutions that require extensive
training and education
taser products are simple clear and
intuitive to use
taser products empower you they don't
confuse you the people at taser believe
that it's safer
that a safer self-defense is a better
self-defense taser devices are available
without a permit in most u.s states
get the taser purse plus or taser strike
light
at taser.com promo code reuben say 15
now at taser.com promo code ruben
spelled t-a-s-e-r dot com
promo code reuben restriction supply see
cite for details
and now back to me all right i'm not
even gonna give much of an intro to this
one
here's aoc lying i'll also say and and
to that we should say why don't you
want our schools to teach
anti-racism why don't republicans
want their kids to know
the tradition of anti-racism in the
united states
why are republicans trying to ban
books in this country why are
republicans trying to ban
speech why are they trying to fire
certain professors
why are they attacking the core roots of
history in this country that strays
anything beyond
what we already know in fact you have
folks like kevin mccarthy
making statements that sound like he's
never even read
martin luther king in his life trying to
ban
books that actually talk about the
history of the civil rights movement and
institutional racism in the united
states
so why don't republicans want us to
learn
how to not be racist why don't
republicans want us
want kids to know how to not be racist
well they're saying it's too young it
makes a question that eliminates this
all right everything she said there was
a lie top to bottom
every single thing that she said there
was a lie
why don't you want our schools to teach
anti-racism
the implication being that schools don't
want to teach
racism right except everyone knows that
that schools teach about racism schools
teach about
slavery schools for the most part give
an honest assessment
of the history of america did any of you
not learn about the civil war did you
not
learn about slavery did you not learn
about american indians being here before
the founding of the united states of
course we
learn all of these things she also says
that kevin mccarthy wants to ban books i
had kevin mccarthy
in here for an hour-long completely
uncensored interview where he made it
very clear i could ask him anything i
wanted and we
don't edit when we do interviews nothing
about banning books
came up okay they're trying to get
critical race theory
which is race essentialism it is
to teach children to be racist to
endlessly
judge everyone on the color of their
skin they're trying to get that
out of schools um but he's not trying to
ban books i have no doubt though that
aoc
would like to ban some books and who are
the very people that are banning books
whether it's abigail schreyer's
books uh book on young girls
transitioning to become boys that
people keep trying to kick off amazon is
called irreversible damage and i've i've
interviewed abigail and the idea that
she's a transphobe is completely
ridiculous
these are the people who want to do all
those things so this is one of those
cases
where every single thing watch the video
again
every single thing that aoc said there
was a lie
and much more of it is applicable to her
and the progressives than anyone on the
conservative side i have
never once met a conservative
or a libertarian i was just at a crazy
libertarian conference
right freedom fest with a bunch of
people who just want individual rights
and be
to be left alone i have never once heard
anyone say let's not
teach racism let's not teach history
let's not teach
about martin luther king she's a liar i
don't know what to do with these people
you know like that's really the the spot
that i'm at that's where what i've been
saying for the last couple weeks like
what do we do about the people who lie
about everything well aoc is basically
on the top of that list because
everything she said to don lemon is a
lie there and then you know lemon then
at the end was like oh well they're
saying
people kids are too young to learn any
of this well actually it's not just that
i don't want a six-year-old
learning about anti-racism which is
racism i don't want a 16 year old
learning it and i certainly don't want
them learning it
at state-funded education centers so i
guess the the answer to this thing is
get your kids out of
public schools get them into charter
schools get them into private schools
and if you can't afford it which is
totally understandable then you should
be pushing
for school choice you should be pushing
to fund
students not systems so right now the
way it basically works is you know your
tax dollars go to this giant system
that is basically beholden to the
teachers union and then they can teach
your kids whatever they want
often teaching them racist ideas that's
what these that's what these ridiculous
people want randy weingarten
who's the head of the the teachers union
well instead of funding these schools
we should fund students which is that
you take the tax money
you give it to the parents the parents
can then decide what they want to do do
they want to do home pods
do they want to do charter schools
private schools is there some other
thing
that they want to do that would be a
much better system but in essence
you can see what they are doing they lie
about everything and they are trying to
destroy
everything and although i don't have
kids yet we don't have kids yet we're
working on it
i can't imagine what negligence it would
be at this point to send your children
to public school yes there must be a few
public schools that have not been
completely infected by this stuff
but unless you want kids with cameras to
to actually be recording what these
crazy teachers are saying
just because they're handed the stuff
right like they're handed the curriculum
and they're handed it and then they're
just reading this stuff
and they're telling white kids that
they're racist and they're talking about
equality instead of
or they're talking about equity instead
of equality and everything else it's
like we had a
big big problem on our hands but
speaking of big problems
the president of the united states
obviously has a severe case of ops this
is old person
syndrome something is not right with joe
biden we all know it
and they can't hide him forever and they
have been leaking him out a little bit
more
every now and again he'll take a
question when he's not supposed to and
then often he says oh i'm going to get
in trouble for that
or he walks up to a microphone and sort
of blathers some incoherent
nonsense well now former presidential
physician
ronnie jackson is coming out and talking
about what he thinks
is going on with biden this is not some
crazy random conspiracy theorist off the
street
this guy was a presidential physician
under george bush
under barack obama and under donald
trump
take a listen absolutely sean and i've
been saying this from the very beginning
i've been saying
that something's going on here i was
saying this when he was candidate joe
biden and i've been saying that it's
only going to get worse and guess what
we're watching that happen right before
our eyes right now and i i'm at the
point right now where you know i went
from
you know telling people we should be
concerned about what might potentially
be going on
to to now saying hey what are what is
happening right now where
where are the the the people in in our
academic medicine that were out there
calling for
for president trump to have a cognitive
test where are these people there's
something seriously going on with this
man right now
and you know i think that he's either
gonna he's either gonna resign they're
gonna convince him to resign from office
at some point in the near future for
medical issues
or they're going to have to use the 25th
amendment to get rid of this man right
now
there's some serious stuff going on
right now and if they do that it'll be
the president's cabinet that initiates
that
and if you've got to imagine if you're a
cabinet member right now if you're the
president of secretary of defense or
secretary of treasury or his attorney
general you have to be looking at him
right now and thinking to yourself like
what is going on can i take direction
from this man right now
and i think that's going to start
happening pretty soon i think there's
going to be some serious pushback
from the white house and from the left
to to do something about what's going on
because
you mentioned in your opening this is a
national security issue at this point
sean it really is
okay that's ronnie jackson former
presidential physician he's not mincing
words there and
basically sounds to me like he's telling
the truth
i don't know what is wrong with joe
biden i am not a doctor and i'm
certainly not joe biden's doctor and
he's not joe biden's doctor either
but he does know a little something
about
medicine he knows a little something
about what it's like to care for the
president
of the united states and he's also just
telling us something
that we all know right he's just telling
us something that we all can see and yet
it's not shown
on mainstream media anywhere and what do
we do
about that chasm what do we do about the
divide
between what we all can see and what
mainstream will
allow us to process together right
because that's the only thing
that kind of holds us together as a
nation it's like this is why we need
a sane and decent and honest media it's
like we're all seeing different stories
right now and depending on who you
follow on twitter and
what youtube shows you watch and
anything else like think how different
your
the set of facts that you guys know and
the ideas that you care about
from watching this show let's say think
how different that is
than someone who's only watching msnbc
or only watching cnn
it's it's pretty staggeringly different
so there was this cnn town hall biden
babbled like i mean it was just
absolutely extraordinary can we grab
that quote
we're going to try to grab a quote from
it i'm going to redo something if we can
pull it up in time
i'm going to read you something that
biden said i think it was originally
tweeted maybe by ali betstucky or
somebody over there
a quote card i sent it out on twitter a
couple days ago we'll see if we can grab
it i think from friday
um biden also the other day was doing a
little press conference and he said he
was on the judiciary committee 150 years
ago
which if that's true uh well then
then he's a vampire um so what what do
we do about this i mean look at
at the end of the day uh you know i
think this is a little
sort of similar ah there we go we got
the quote i'll get to it in just a
second
can you make that a little bit bigger if
possible on the prompter um
i think this is sort of similar to the
airlock situation with covid
lab leak so for about a year there was a
certain amount of people
online who were saying oh there is a
chance
that kovid leaked from a wuhan lab
there's a chance that maybe we had
funded some of this stuff
like there's a chance right and what
were they told they were told that they
were conspiracy
theorists they were told they were crazy
people they were told that they should
be banned from twitter and everywhere
else
and then for a year that basically went
on and then remember what happened about
a month ago
jon stewart went on stephen colbert's
show and said something
about the kovid lab leak theory and then
suddenly everyone in the mainstream
media felt that they could talk about it
because the airlock had basically been
broken right so it's like oh
jon stewart said it a good decent
standard liberal
has said it so now we can all say what
those crazy right-wingers
were saying this entire time and i sense
that's going to be exactly what happens
mark my words i'm saying this at the end
of july
2021. mark my words that's sort of
what's going to be
what's going to happen here that it's
going to be something like barack obama
over the next couple months
will probably be in an interview and do
one off-handed sentence where he he'll
be like something like oh you know joe
isn't exactly
what he used to be or maybe joe's lost
the staff a step or or maybe it'll be as
far as maybe joe should think about
stepping down or something like that
and then suddenly everyone in the media
is going to pretend
that now they can all talk about it and
that you know suddenly all the people
who are they were calling crazy for
talking about it this whole time
like i think you got the point there so
okay i'm going to read this quote this
is an exact quote
that joe biden said to don lemon
at this cnn town hall i have to look a
little low because we're doing this off
the computer here but just listen to the
quote
you tell me if this makes sense i can't
even read it as slowly and
confused as joe biden but just tell me
if this makes any sense
and the question is whether or not we
should be in a position
where our why can't the experts say
we know that this virus is in fact it's
going to be
or excuse we know why all the drugs
approved
are not temporarily approved but
permanently approved
that's underway too
that's just one little thing and you can
watch the video on that
and i just again i just want to say one
other thing this is not me being
partisan or me being an
[ __ ] or me not being sympathetic to
old people or people with cognitive
decline or any of those things
okay i've told you guys this before i
spent a lot of time
in new york with my with my grandma who
had
the beginnings of dementia in the last
couple years of her life and was
constantly repeating herself and
forgetting things
and becoming frustrated and guess what
there was actually some beauty to it too
because in some ways she forgot a lot of
the things that she used to worry about
and complained about she really became
a really wonderful quite spectacular
person at the at the end of her life she
always was but really like we
we bonded an incredible way and because
i was doing stand-up at night
i had a lot of free time during the day
and i would take her to doctors several
times a week
um and she had other health things too
and i would take her to doctors and the
repetition
and taking the cognitive tests and all
of those things so i don't say any of
this lightly
but like if you're one if you're a
journalist if you're a journalist right
now who's not
saying something about something we all
can see are you a journalist
and and if you're someone who believes
that america uh
is good and you believe that the office
of the presidency matters and that any
of the political stuff that any of this
matters
like and you're trying to hide it or not
talk about what you can see
because it's your guy in office like are
you are you a
patriotic american at that point like so
i'm not a conspiracy theorist those of
you that are seeing these things you're
not conspiracy theorists you're not
crazy people
i don't think you're trying to be dicks
about it i'm certainly not trying to be
a dick about it
but something ain't right and that was
former white house physician ronnie
uh was it john ronnie johnson uh what
was it
ronnie jackson sorry rondy jackson
basically saying that right there so
make of it what you will but my guess
i'm just putting this as a little let's
just put a little pin
on dave rubin today my little pin is
that barack obama probably will
be the one who breaks the airlock on it
very similarly
to how jon stewart broke the airlock on
the covid labley thing all right so
speaking of covid let's uh let's move
because you know
the hypocrisy just doesn't end with
these people and you know my friend
michael malus
often says and walter kern who was on
the show a couple weeks ago on our
friday panel
makes the point of saying that something
good is happening right now because the
lies are just coming out faster and
faster so
sort of like the first segment i did on
aoc it's like everyone knows you're
lying about all that stuff
not everyone but a lot of people fouchy
you flip flop
every which way it's like you guys are
red pilling people left and right
because
the average person has some uh memory
right we have some memory of you saying
one thing and then saying another thing
and everything else
so here is fauci now saying that masked
mandates for fully vaccinated americans
are going to be quite understandable
so it's quite understandable neil why
local authorities are now saying
good that you're vaccinated but in a
situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask
good that you're vaccinated but people
indoors
should wear a mask that local
authorities should be deciding that well
guys science tells us the vaccine works
right isn't that what he's telling us
so if you are vaccinated you should be
allowed to be out there we're also told
now the new thing is that
uh that the vaccine doesn't really stop
the delta variant which everyone's
freaking over but you will get
less lesser symptoms in essence okay
i think they're missing the point here
i'm going to actually try to give fauchi
the benefit of the doubt which it's
getting very hard to do
but the point that they're missing is
that humans need to
move on we need to move on from this
right
some people are going to get sick it is
possible that
uh that kovid will be with us in some
form or another forever at this point
and there will be people
who get sick there will people who get
different variants
maybe it will morph into something else
you should take whatever precautions you
want to take you know my feelings about
vaccines and if you want to wear masks
and all of those things
but the fact that still now we are over
a year and a half
after two weeks to flatten the curve and
now he's
kind of saying yeah if you're indoors
wear a mask even if you're vaccinated
it's like when does life
ever become normal again and then
there's these other people that'll say
well no this is the new normal
and again guys if you could snap your
fingers if you could snap your fingers
and go back to a year and a half ago
would you do it
go back to that life a year and a half
ago would you do it i think pretty much
everybody would except our ruling class
accept the fouchies except the democrat
governors except the people who want to
endlessly
control you i can tell you here in los
angeles where now there is an
indoor mask mandate whether you're
vaccinated or not
well first off a lot of people aren't
doing it the sheriff has said he will
not enforce it
i went into the mall i did not wear a
mask
some people were marrying me where were
wearing masks some people were not
wearing masks
and when you see someone who's not
wearing mess there's a nice human moment
and you can actually see them smile
because you can see their mouth it's
quite extraordinary actually because
human interaction
and us being social creatures is an
important part of the whole damn
thing um when i went into bloomingdale's
i went into bloomingdale's to get a
bathing suit because i'm going off the
grid
i did not have a mask on a sales
associate came up to me very nicely he
said sir could you put on your mask and
i did because i was not there to get
into a fight with this guy or get this
guy
fired or any bit of trouble or have them
call the police even though we know the
police won't
won't do anything about it but i think
you can do
what is right for you in your life i'm
not being a dick about it i'm actually
going to get the
the antibody test later today at 3 30 so
stay tuned
on that because everyone has to make
decisions for themselves anyway i want
to show you some other
tweets that we've got here so back in
march of 2020
people were saying very very different
things
about kobe so let's throw this first
tweet up here uh this is
chris hayes uh do i have this one here
oh i think my papers are a little out of
order guys
um oh it's okay it's on screen here uh
trump's obsession
focus on a vaccine is nuts it's totally
immaterial to the short-term
challenges which are substantial now i
want you to really think about that
let's leave that up for just a second
uh this is back basically a little over
a year ago
when trump was pushing for a vaccine and
you've got the eight o'clock i guess he
guess he's on this guy's on at eight
o'clock i don't know what time chris
hayes is on nobody nobody really knows
what times chris hayes is on and nobody
should know
but basically he's saying that trump
because he's pushing for a vaccine is
nuts these are the very same people who
all want you to get vaccinated
immediately
right now he slightly has walked back
from that on twitter over the last
couple days
then there's that that real uh
piece of work joy reid over on msnbc and
this is when trump
was president the trump administration
has so
broken the federal government and
several state governments
thanks to sycophantic governors like ron
desantis brian kemp
greg abbott christine gnome etc etc i
can't even conceive
how we put it back together and restore
credibility i mean will
anyone anyone at all ever fully trust
the cdc again
and who on god's earth would trust a
vaccine approved by the fda
how do we get a vaccine distributed
after this broken trumpist nonsense has
infected everything
even if biden wins really think about
that think about the level
of partisan insanity that these people
pushed out there
we have chris hayes basically saying
trump's focusing on a vaccine and that's
going to kill people and this woman
saying joy reid saying we can't even
trust the cdc anymore because of trump
these are the same exact people who now
will tell you everything that the cdc is
right
and that of course you should get
vaccinated and it's the unvaccinated
people who are the problem
even though it was them telling people
we're focusing too much on vaccines and
vaccines are probably evil
because of trump this is what causes
people to have bipolar disorder i'm
fairly certain like if you watch these
people
the way they flip-flop you know it's one
thing to change your opinion i hear this
often
well dave you changed your opinion on
things you used to be a bernie
supporting leftists we've seen the
videos on youtube i'm not proud of those
videos by the way
but you know what happened to me i got
new information
like that seminal moment that all of you
have seen when i sat down with larry
elder talking about systemic racism
and i couldn't back up my position and
larry had facts and information
that's not flip-flopping when you evolve
to a new position because of new
information
flip-flopping is when because one guy
you don't like says something you say
something and then when the guy you like
says something you say something else
and that's what all of these
people are doing we'll throw rachel
maddow in there too we've got
a maddow tweet trump has plotted
with his team on a pre-election
promotional campaign
to try to convince voters a vaccine is
safe approved and ready for mass
distribution
even if none of that is true yet well of
course
as we know it turned out to be
completely true and it's
exactly the same vaccine that they are
trying to push on
everybody right now how do you not go
crazy in the madness you know how i
knocked i don't go crazy in the madness
i usually don't tweet on weekends and
i'm about
to take a month off of all of this and
and relax and restore
and everything else but it is a big week
i just interviewed congressman jim
jordan from ohio we talk all about the
big tech stuff
he is really trying to bring some bills
in not to regulate big tech per se
uh but at the very least to possibly
break them up
and and you know harm some of the
monopolistic power that they have part
one of my interview
with uh jim jordan is up on youtube now
the full episode
is up at reubenreport.locals.com oh
and you know that ben shapiro guy the
fastest talking jew on all of
youtube uh he has a new book coming out
this week i just interviewed him
this morning and uh it's a good one the
book comes out tomorrow part one will
come out tomorrow as well is that right
yes and the full will be at
reubenreport.locals.com
we've got a jam-packed week as i said
friday we got a couple couple big
announcements there's a lot of good
stuff going on with locals
the pre-sale for my next book will begin
on
friday it comes out in april but i'm
excited to finally share the title with
you the cover
really the the mission of the book the
purpose of the book i think it's
i think it's just the right extension of
don't burn this book it's sort of part
two i would say probably in what will be
a trilogy actually
because in uh don't burn this book i
sort of laid out
what my beliefs are and the framework
that i think is the best framework for
an america or a western society to be
free and of course those are the
classically liberal
positions that i hold this book is okay
well now
we're getting away from a lot of that
stuff but how do you
and i thrive in that atmosphere because
i've been able to despite this craziness
and i want to
impart some of that on you guys so i
think you're going to dig it uh
and if you want to communicate with me
directly for live streams live chat and
more reubenreport.locals.com
all right have a great day everybody see
you tomorrow